hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're going
to be going over a famous game from the
1985 World Championships between
Kasparov and Karpov two of the greatest
chess minds of all time and probably one
of the greatest chess rivalries that
we've seen in a very long time Karpov is
going to be playing the white pieces and
Kasparov is going to be playing the
black pieces starts out with pawn to e4
pawn c5 Kasparov deciding to play the
sicilian offense a very aggressive
defense can lead to not only a draw but
a lot of times has a very high wind
percentage for black if you look at kind
of all the defenses this has a very good
win percentage for black so really tough
to see right now if Kasparov is going to
play for a draw or to play for the win
but Sicilian definitely gives him a lot
of different chances white continues
here with Knight to f3 and Kasparov
plays pawn to e6 now he does have other
options here a lot of times from here
you may see pawn to d6 kind of going
into the dragon if you're familiar with
that variation of the Sicilian or the
Nash Dorf which you'll see a lot of
different times but this bar I've
decided instead to play pawn to e6 from
here white continues up the board
pushing forward with pawn to d4 very
common in the Sicilian to go ahead and
attack this pawn on c5 and kind of
challenge the center to kind of see what
black is going to do here because part
of decides to go ahead and take and
after the knight recaptures here on d4
then kabob now will develop his own
Knight to c6 now a lot of time
lower-rated chess players will jump at
any opportunity to exchange pieces in
this case the knight takes on c6 a lot
of times higher level chess players
usually try to develop their pieces left
follically and then try to formulate a
gameplan and then kind of base their
moves based on that game plan really
don't want to try to exchange pieces
early on that's exactly what Karpov
decides to do in this case and he
actually plays Knight to b5 here he's
really eyeing down this d6 square it
doesn't really matter where Kasparov
plays right here let's say he brings his
knight
to f6 Karpov can now bring is Knight to
d6 and after the exchange here because
obviously the king is in check this is
going to be pretty hard for Kasparov to
play against simply because his lights
were a bishop here it's going to be very
difficult for him to get this out
obviously black cannot castle on the
King side because the Queen's here she's
kind of a thorn in cat's barhop side not
necessarily to say that black doesn't
have a possible good game here but
needless to say is cuz barb doesn't
really want to get into this situation
so with that said because Karpov did
play and Knight to be five because far
I've decided to play pawn to d6 now this
does a couple things obviously this
pretty much thoughts all of Karpov ideas
of bringing his Knight to d6 but at the
same time it allows him later on to play
a six can kind of push this Knight off
of the b5 square really the only square
for this night to go once he's kicked
off is c3 and a3
now keep in mind he's not really going
to come to c3 because then he's blocking
his own knight in so he's really going
to end up on a three now if we look at
like that you never really want to have
your knight on the rim either the a or
the H file so because of this d6 move
that's pretty obvious to Gary Kasparov I
really don't really like this move from
Karpov from Knight to b5 but that's kind
of what Karpov was thinking is eyeing
down on this d6 we're from here Kasparov
karpov now played pawn to c4 trying to
get kind of a spatial advantage here
because Farah has really allowed white
to dominate the center of the board
playing d6 and not pushing his pawn up
further so White's trying to take
advantage of that so he's starting to
put some pressure on the center of the
board as you can see he has a lot of
pressure on this d5 square here with
both of his pawns in his queen kind of
lined up on this d5 square from here
Kasparov plays Knight to f6 again top
level play you always want to start to
develop your pieces
Apsara does exactly that brings Knight
to f6 makes way for his King to castle
on the Kings side obviously he just has
to move his Bishop and also adding
pressure on this pawn right here on e4
now from here white plays Knight to c3
again simple development at the same
time he's also defending this pawn on e4
that's now being attacked from Kasparov
as part of now decides to go and kick
this knight off he's going to have to
kick it off sometimes who decided to go
ahead and play pawn to a6 and as we
talked about before the knight is now
going to have to come back to a3 not
really the best position for this Knight
can't really move anywhere right now
can't come back to b5 he'll lose or if
he brings it to c4 obviously there's a
pawn here right now so white right now
has a good spatial advantage in the
center of the board with his pawns here
on c4 and E 4 but is night here on a3 is
kind of a pain he's going to have to do
something about that later on
now from here because barb has two
different options the most likely that
you'll see a lot of times is Bishop to
e7 again just simple development move
getting his pieces involved in the game
getting ready to cast on the Kings side
the bishop may come to e2 and then both
sides may Castle this is typical
Kasparov
does not play typical usually he studies
openings but a lot of us have really
never thought about before and that's
exactly what he plays here he plays pawn
to d5 which is actually if you kind of
look at all the different variations of
how you can play it conspire of ops to
play this as a gambit so he's actually
going to give up a pawn so that he can
have rapid development in a very good
align for
attacking White's King side so from here
Kasparov excuse me Karpov takes on d5
and after the exchanges here on d5 white
again retakes on d5 and now the knight
comes to b4 now you can already see that
this night has come past the fifth rank
which is the fourth rank for white but
there's a lot more attacking lines here
black already has a night here on f6
getting into the game there's no way for
white really to kick this night off as
before we saw that pawn could come to a6
well the pawn cannot come to a3 here
from white so as you can already see
this is a little bit different as far as
Kaspar bringing his his knight past the
fifth rank as it was from Karpov
bringing his knight past the fourth rank
to give everyone a little bit of context
on the next move this actual position
had been breached before and white
played Bishop to c4 trying to protect
this pawn here on d5 again white is of a
pawn material so a lot of times if
you're up in material you want to hold
on to that advantage but from here black
decided to bring his Bishop to g4 in the
previous game and this led to a draw so
Karpov actually found a much better
improvement from his bishop here on c4
and instead of bringing his Bishop to c4
he now brought his Bishop to e2 which is
a vast improvement because in the game
before after his Bishop came to see for
the Bishop came down to g4 then the
bishop came back to e2 so you can see
there is kind of a wasted move from
white so Karpov saw this in his earlier
game and decided instead of playing to
c4 I'm going to go ahead and play my
Bishop to e2 so that's kind of the
context that we see this Bishop to e2
now from here black decided again you
always want to develop your pieces as
fast as you can and in this case you
want to develop them towards the center
for center control this is a great
square from black obviously he wants to
get his dark square Bishop into the
game's weakened castle as soon as you
can
so this is a great square Bishop to c5
putting a lot of pressure on the King
side at the same time getting ready to
castle from here we decide we see both
sides to go ahead and Castle white
castles and black castles as well
and now white now brings his bishop to
f3 now again we're no longer worried
about the bishop coming down to g4
because now it could just be taken if he
wanted to
at the same time white does still want
to try to hold on to this advantage that
he has on d5 black kind of has a spatial
advantage as far as his minor pieces
kind of moved up the board so white does
have a small advantage in his pawn on d5
so he kind of wants to hold on to that
so bring his bishop to f3 is a great way
to do both of those things from here
black is going to bring his bishop to f5
again getting his last minor piece
developed into the game at the same time
really dominating the center of the
board
we have this bishop here on c5 and this
Bishop here on f5 kind of dominating the
d4 and the e4 square anytime you develop
your pieces you really want to control
the center of the board that's why we
bring our Knight to c6 and f6 because
they really control the center of the
board so these are great development
moves from black as he continues his
development from here White's going to
bring his Bishop to g5 as most people do
they like to bring their bishop pinning
down pieces to other pieces from here as
you can see the knight is pinned down to
the Queen on d8 so this Knights not
going to be able to move for some time
now from here the rook is going to come
to e8 again rooks belong on semi open
files or open files because Favre
already has all his minor pieces
developed and so now you want to get
your major pieces involved in the game
it's not the other way around you don't
want to start getting your rooks before
your minor pieces are developed so his
minor pieces are developed he now brings
his rook to e8 fantastic move getting it
involved on this efile from here why
decides to bring his Queen to d2 again
adding a little pressure defense on this
Bishop on g5 and at the same time he's
really wants to connect his rooks
anytime you can develop all your minor
pieces get your Queen in the game and
connect your rooks that's a good thing
so that's a great starting thing for
Karpov and now both sides kind of decide
on how the rest of the game is going to
go forward so conspire I've looked at
the game and he kind of saw all those
minor pieces are developed now what
should he really do so a lot of times
even without thinking of what's good for
you think about
what's bad for your opponent what
Kasparov saw here is the one weakness
that white really has is his night here
on a3 as we talked about all those other
pieces are completely fine they're
controlling the center they're
well-developed but this night here on a3
is kind of a problem and they're really
only move that this can make is Knight
to c4 obviously he can start to come
back but you never really want to bring
your pieces back just waiting in defense
for your opponent to attack so in this
case Gaspar I've decided that Bishop or
excuse me pawn to b5 is a fantastic move
it kind of locks in this night here on
a3 anytime you can lock your opponent's
pieces from getting involved in the game
that's a good move so that's exactly
what Kasparov does with that move pawn
to b5 now from here the rook is going to
come to d1 again this is a semi-open
file and rooks belong behind your own
pawns especially on a semi-open file so
we can really start to push this pawn at
the board if he wants to now from here
because Parr plays a great move and this
kind of sets the tone for the rest of
the game and it's Knight to d3 again he
does have pressure obviously White's not
going to take with his Queen here
because it's being defended by this
bishop here but this really is going to
be a fornum Whiteside the rest of the
game it's going to be really hard for
white to kick this Knight off anytime
soon because you can see his Knights
aren't going to get there anytime soon
and his bishop is going to have to lose
a lot of tempos to try to kick this
night off so what's really going to have
to worry about this night for the rest
of the game which is why it's a
fantastic move for black
now from here Karpov obviously realized
that his night here on a3 was a problem
so he decided to bring his knight to be
one he needs to get in a better square
so this is the first move that he asked
to make Knight to b1
now from here Kasparov plays h6 trying
to trade off his knight here for this
Bishop on g5 now keep in mind this is an
open game anytime it's an open game
Bishop's tend to fare a little better
especially at Grandmaster play most
players prefer bishops so in this place
Karpov is not going to exchange now I do
feel like his move probably wasn't that
great he actually probably
should have exchanges because cuz profs
putting a lot of pressure on the center
of the board
and so anytime pressure is being put on
you anytime you can exchange pieces kind
of alleviate some of the pressure I
think it's a good thing
Karpov decided there wasn't too much
pressure that he should be worried about
so he decided to decline and bring his
bishop back back to h4 now from here
black just continued relentlessly up the
board started putting even more and more
pressure on white hair playing pawn to
b4 attacking the knight here on c3 and
trying to force white to really make a
mistake and get all his pieces out of
whack here again this knight here is
nicely placed on c3 defending and
attacking the center of the board
so he's kind of testing that to see
where this Knight is going to go the
knight now comes to a four and as you
can see here white now has a knight here
on B 1 and a 4 that's not really what
you want your Knights to be doing in a
game being on the very bottom or on the
side of the board they can't really do
much so from here obviously as you can
see the knight was attacking the bishop
here on c5 because 5 does not really
want to get rid of one of his most
valuable pieces his bishop there on c5
so he decides to bring it back to a
central square he does not want exchange
right away and he so he brings it back
to d6 nice central square for his Bishop
at the same time avoiding the exchange
now from here white plays Bishop to g3
now keep in mind this dark square bishop
or white right now is not doing anything
but the Starks square bishop for black
is doing a whole lot it's very central
and it's very very active so anytime
your opponent has a piece that's active
and you have one that's not it's really
a good idea to exchange those pieces off
the board because it's just good for you
so in this case Karpov sees this he now
brings his Bishop back to g3 so he
decides that he wants to go ahead and
exchange these pieces off the board so
from here black decides he doesn't need
to worry about that right away he does
have his queen protecting it so he
brings his rook to c8 again you want
your rooks on open files or semi open
files that's exactly what black does now
Karpov now brings his pawns
to be three again he now has a night on
a four he has to do something about it
he can't bring it to be six because of
the Queen he can't bring it to excuse me
see three here because of the pawn so he
really needs to bring it back to b2 so
that he can get it to let's say c4 and
start getting involved in the game the
only way he can do that is if it brings
this pawn to c3
now Kasparov starts to really expand on
the kingside and he plays pawn to g5 now
that says a few things and it really
locks down the dark squares on the King
side but the same time this night here
on f6 can now get involved in the game
before is we talked about this night
here on f6 what's kind of pinned down so
anytime that one of your pieces that's
been pinned down is no longer pinned
down try to see where you can actively
get that piece involved in the game so
this night here on f6 is really going to
be a huge part of Kasparov splaying
going forward now here why decided to go
ahead and exchange off pieces exactly
what we talked about before is dark
square Bishop is not doing much exchange
it for Bishop that is doing a lot into
the game the Queen obviously has to take
on d6 and now white plays pawn to g3
really allowing this bishop if he needs
to to really kind of have an escape
square this is kind of a huge key
defender for white so he's really trying
to have an escape score if he needs it
to kind of fall back now from here black
plays Knight to d7 again as we talked
about Kasparov can now get his knight
involved in the game can't really do it
now but if he brings it to d7
he can then nicely place it on e5 this
is a much stronger place than it was
here on f6 f6 is kind of controlling the
silver borer Butkus Prado is ready to
attack so if he brings it to e5 this is
putting a lot of pressure on white
so from here White's going to play
Bishop back to g2 as we talked about
trying to get a little safety really
trying to protect his King side because
you realized that there's starting to be
a lot of pressure on the King side from
Kasparov now black decides to bring is
Queen back to f6 for two reasons one to
kind of control this long diagonal
obviously you want your bishops and
Queens to controls much
as possible that's why they're better in
open games and at the same time as we'll
see he's kind of eyeing down on this F
file once this Bishop comes off the
board he's really eyeing down on this f2
pawn
now from here White's going to play pawn
to a3 this is kind of a thorn in his
side this pawn here on b4 and so Chris
probably just plays a5 so that he can
just exchange and he still has a pawn
here on b4 now White's going to bring
his Queen to a2 and now the bishop is
going to come back to g6 again he's
still putting a lot of pressure with his
LightSquared bishop on the middle but
again he does really want his dark
squared bishop excuse me his dark square
Queen here to really control this long
dark diagonal at the same time to put
pressure on this f2 square now the next
move from a lot of people's opinion is
probably the worst move the Karpov
played in the game he still has a lot of
fighting chances he's still up in
material so it's not like the game is
lost by Karpov by any means he still has
great King side safety everything is OK
the one good thing he does have he is up
in material his next move is really kind
of a question mark from a lot of people
and that's pawn to d6 really doesn't do
a lot I guess he thought that Kasparov
would take the pawn on d6 kind of lose a
tempo so white can kind of get back in
the game he probably could have played
you know Bishop to h1 if he kind of
wants a waiting move or even pawn to h3
so Kasparov can't kind of push up the
board any more or it could have even
played king - h1 is kind of a waiting
move and getting his king off of this f2
as far as if there's an attack on the f2
square but again he decided not to
instead he played pawn to d6 now
Kasparov is up in as far as his
development in his attack there's no way
he's going to waste a move on a mere
pawn on d6 he's not trying to capture a
pawn on d6 he's trying to capture this
king here on G 1 so Kasparov plays pawn
to g4 just again putting a lot of more
pressure on the white king side here
from here why it's going to come back to
d2 trying to centralize and at the same
time protect as many squares as you can
on the board and now the black King
comes to g7 as you can see this bishop
here on d2 it's attacking many of the
squares one of those being this pawn
here on h6 so black has to centralize
his King a little bit and protect this
pawn here on h6 now the pawn from here
comes to f3 from Karpov I kind of think
this is a mistake
anytime you feel keto your Bishop to the
King side any time you start to move
your other pawns it's significantly
weakened your King side in this case as
you can see this long diagonal this dark
diagonal attacking the King it's going
to be a huge weakness and you will see
Kasparov kind of exploit that later on
into the game now from here because
probably sides to go ahead and take the
pawn here on d6 so now both sides are
even in material because you can see
it's going to be really hard for white
to attack this King here on d7 but black
has a lot of opportunities to attack
this white King especially now that this
pawn came to f3 it's kind of opened the
door for crisp RF to attack from here
white decided to go ahead and take here
on g4 yes he did does go up in material
but at the same time you can kind of see
the door opening forcus para now
Kasparov does bring his queen to d4
anytime a door opens especially if your
name is cos Farah you attack you open
that door and you crush your opponent
that's exactly what he does in this game
Karpov here brings his King back to h1
and now Kasparov brings his knight to f6
obviously before as we talked about he
could bring it to e5 but now he wants to
even push farther so he brings it to f6
so that he can now take on g4 if he
wants to or he can even bring it to e4
if he wants to
now from here Karpov decided to kind of
challenge the center obviously you never
want you know your opponent to have
their Queen kind of in your base kind of
running things
so Karpov decides to play rook to f4 and
this is kind of a deciding move in the
game from Kasparov because he plays a
fantastic move that really challenges
everything Karpov is trying to do as far
as protecting his house so if you want
to go ahead and pause and
you can find Kasparov best move will
kind of go forward from there hopefully
you
you found Knight to e5 kind as we talked
about before it's a fantastic move and
really it's hard for Karpov not to lose
this exchange
Karpov decides to take the knight there
on d3 and now the knight can come to f2
attacking the King and at the same time
forking this Queen here on d3 there's no
real other option except to take and now
the bishop can come into d3 and capture
the Queen so this was obviously a good
exchange for Chris barb and he still has
a lot of pressure on the board with his
rooks just getting ready to come into
the game now the risk is going to come
to d2 trying to put some pressure on
this D file but from here the Queen's
just going to come down to e3 fantastic
move there's not a whole lot white can
do here we'll go ahead and finish it out
though he now captures the bishop there
on d3 and now a fantastic move Kasparov
brings his rook down to c1 from here the
game is kind of over Karpov can actually
kind of resign from here there's not
much he can do he does play it out but
if you kind of analyze this move is so
phenomenal as far as you know what was
Kasparov is playing actually in the game
his plan was rook to c1 fantastic move
from here obviously he can't take with
you know his rook he'll lose even faster
so he does decide to bring his knight to
be - to add a little bit more protection
on his rook on d1 and now the Queen
comes to f2 is you can start to see
starting to put more and more pressure
onto the King side again the rook still
can't come to c1 because then the rook
would come down to e1 and it's going to
be quicker a lot faster but from here
the knight does come to d2 trying to
come to the aid of the protection of his
king and from here rook captures on d1
now if you look in the game he actually
could have brought his rook down to e2
probably could have checked made it a
little faster but you know tomahto
tomato doesn't really matter he and said
took on d1 and after the knight came
down to
you want to recapture then the route
came to e1 in it's good game Karpov
decided to resign in this case as you
can see there's really nothing they can
do it's going to be good game from here
so fantastic game from Kasparov as you
can see he's just relentlessly attacked
Karpov and he saw a small little
disadvantage from white and he attacked
it early and then he realized that he
could just completely annihilate the
kingside from white so hopefully you
guys enjoy the video if you haven't
already please subscribe and I will see
you guys in the next video thanks for
watching